this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer mike epstein
heard outlaws and legends is a
competitive riff on the co-op
multiplayer heist game where two teams
or four mary men and women
simultaneously attempt to unlock a vault
and extract a giant chest of gold
however it's stealthy race to elude
computer-controlled knights and rival
players rarely plays out with the grace
implied by the concept
more often the competition for keys
chests and respawn points devolve into
protracted brawls that showcase clumsy
combat
throw in some confusing ui easily
exploitable stealth kill mechanics
and myriad small design flaws and hoods
execution fails to deliver the goods
each match in herd has four phases steal
the vault key from the invincible but
generally unaware sheriff
find and open the vault carry the chest
to one of few extraction points on the
map
use a winch to lift the chest while
defending the players doing this
the other team meanwhile has the
opportunity to disrupt the mission and
try to acquire the key or the chess for
themselves
with both teams naturally meeting at a
few locations you have plenty of
opportunities to surprise and overtake
the objective
in this idealized version of the game
the match is a coordinated stealth run
where each character uses their unique
skills to advance the mission or help
their teammates
each of the four characters
theoretically has a role to play
marion the stealth fighter moves quickly
and has abilities that let her steal the
key or assassinate enemies discreetly
robin's bow allows him to take out
enemies from afar little john can lift
gates and move the chest quickly
tuck is a solid backup fighter with a
wide-ranging melee attack and a healing
ability
though some of these skills make certain
characters well-suited to different
tasks there's no moment where you need a
specific character and their skills
this opens the door for players to
choose characters based on their play
styles but also minimizes the importance
of class based play around the heist
itself
ultimately the character combat
abilities matter more than their other
affinities
though hood is primarily pitched as a
game about heists things get more
chaotic and aggressive when you add
another team of players
rather than picking each other off or a
coordinate ambush
most matches devolve into a series of
team battles for control of the key
the chest or the winch once the fighting
starts any pretense of a stealth mission
falls away the ai controlled knights
while powerful enough to overwhelm any
one player if they are in large numbers
are still easy enough to avoid that most
players will engage each other even if
it means getting spotted by them
even the sheriff who instantly kills you
when he gets in range and can only be
temporarily stunned
is slow enough that you can fight around
him
sheriff here hood's unwieldy combat
mechanics make large battles painful
whether you win
or lose though every character has some
capacity for hand-to-hand fighting
hood's melee attacks feel loose they're
difficult to aim
or time well on the receiving end most
attacks stun slightly leading to a
situation in large battles where a
single hit will leave you stun locked
in theory you have either a parry or
dodge to keep an enemy from hitting you
but it's nearly impossible to keep track
of all the action in a scrum
these large clumsy battles can turn into
minutes long
wars of attrition where players fight
die respawn and run right back into the
fray until one side wipes the other out
giving themselves enough time to make
progress this is especially true in the
winching phase of the match
where one team needs to defend a fixed
point then there's the assassination
issue
any player can stealth kill an opponent
by crouching behind them and hitting a
prompt
it doesn't matter if the assassins
already been seen or even if the two
have been fighting previously
this frequently leads to situations
where one player will engage another
openly only to get assassinated by
another player waiting in the wings
getting assassinated mid-fight feels
abrupt and inappropriate in the
situation and
at times it feels unavoidable and is
therefore extremely aggravating
similarly robin hood can kill other
players with a fully charged headshot
while it isn't
always possible to land one especially
while getting attacked
it also leads to frustrating sudden
deaths in and out of combat
while this kind of combat seems
appropriate for a stealthy combat
experience
its unregulated use feels more
disruptive than additive
more like an exploit than a
well-considered mechanic since a team
can get wiped out quickly matches can
turn on a dime
your team getting the key and moving it
to an extraction point doesn't have any
bearing on whether or not you'll be able
to beat the other team
all you need to do to win is winch the
last of seven progress pips
matches where your team does all of the
work can still be stolen at the last
moment
sometimes a steal feels earned but
sometimes it doesn't
either way it doesn't really feel like
the better team always wins
whether you play the objective or you go
after the other team hood requires a lot
of coordination
the best teams attack as a group and
find ways to cater to their best players
as strengths
heard features a ping system that allows
for some non-verbal communication
but when you're predicting enemy
movements or noting something not in
direct line of sight you need to be able
to say more
it also helps to relay intel when you
get it for example
when you steal the key you learn the
location of the vault which isn't on the
map
without chat it would be impossible to
share that information
hood's in-game party chat is on by
default which seems to prompt
matchmaking assembled group to chat
more than other multiplayer games but
there's no substitute for playing this
game with friends
you can experience the pure heist
version of the game without a second set
of players but sadly that pure pve
experience is regulated to a practice
mode which doesn't give you any
experience or goal to unlock and earn
cosmetics or character perks
without any opportunity to experience a
narrative or make meta progress
the practice feels slightly wasteful of
time especially since it's also not
great practice for the main pvp ve
experience
that said it's not a major problem that
hood sidesteps the law that so many
multiplayer games feel compelled to
build
in fact hood definitely uses a robin
hood myth to get around it there's
almost no story in hood you can earn
text-based snippets of character
information but there's no plot per se
while that leaves open the question of
why there are two rival bands of thieves
the story doesn't really feel missing
all you really need to know is that
robin hood and his band of thieves steal
from the rich and give to the poor
chances are if you were drawn to this
game you've already got the gist of it
it's not without its own sense of style
though hood does try to put its own
slightly darker edgier spin on the robin
hood universe
the character designs are more
intimidating than the simple green garb
took hood's take on friar attack for
example
looks more like a shaman than a monk the
more brutal aesthetic touches feel in
line with all the killing you do on any
given heist but without any real story
to spotlight those characterization
changes they don't really register
without interesting characters or a
story the focus falls solely on the
gameplay
and hood's gameplay feels sloppy it's a
heist game that usually devolves into a
wild frustrating
melee combat arena in its best moments
it's a tense highly cooperative
experience
but those moments never last long i want
to believe in the competitive heist hood
tries to pull off and
in theory a living multiplayer game
could evolve into something better over
time but still there are too many points
of frustration built into the experience
to expect that hood's evolution will be
something transformative
[Music]
you